what's so fascinating is if you just
take it to the extreme and i forget who
i heard say this but i thought it was so
just so articulate if the debt doesn't
matter if the printing of money doesn't
matter then let's just print three
quadrillion dollars
right like if it literally doesn't
matter then like let's just add a bunch
more zeros to the end when we're
printing and rather than have two
trillion dollar uh you know stimulus
bills let's literally just do a two
quadrillion stimulus bill now obviously
nobody who is sane or uh sirius would
ever actually argue to do that
because it does matter to some degree
and no come on if it was that easy pomp
we talked about this you know when we
first met
if
if creating wealth was as simple as
printing money
wouldn't everyone do that wouldn't every
country just print money
that's not how wealth is created right i
mean i have in my office i go get it for
you a 100 trillion zimbabwe dollar bill
wouldn't buy a loaf of bread
100 trillion dollars
right that i own i couldn't buy a loaf
of bread in zimbabwe
so how many bolivars does it take to buy
a chicken in venezuela how many pesos in
argentina
you know it's just this fallacy
that debt and deficits don't oh but
we're the world reserve currency
well
for now
you know the uk was the world reserve
currency for 75 years
and they thought they could spend as
much as they wanted
just like we do and they thought they
could invade anybody they wanted to just
like we do and in 1913 they invaded
mesopotamia
incurred a bunch of debt the pound
started and collapsed the dollar
ascended 30 years later bretton woods we
became the world reserve currency then
coincidentally we invaded mesopotamia
incurred a bunch of debt the dollar
collapsed the remnant be ascended china
became oh wait that hasn't happened yet
it will
you think you think that the chinese
reinman b will end up being the global
reserve currency
yep
why what walk me through kind of what
the the thought process of where we are
today to how we get there yeah so
um
profitly get spending
in the u.s right all empires fail the
same way whether it's the british empire
the roman empire the ottoman empire they
all fail the same way through massive
amounts of debt when you become
massively indebted you only got four
choices you can pay it back
you couldn't do that right you could tax
the assets of all the people in the
united states their wealth forget their
income
tax all their wealth you couldn't pay
back the debt
all of it can do it so you can't pay it
back so then you can restructure it
problem is if you structure it someone's
got to take the other side no one's
going to take the other side
third you can default on it
emerging markets default all the time
but we can't do that because there's no
imf to bail us out
and oh by the way if you default what
happens you get kicked out of power and
then politicians like to stay in power
fourth you can devalue it and that's
what we will do so we will continue to
devalue says oh the dollar's so strong
the dollar's so strong no it's not
the dollar's down versus the remnb over
the last two years
fact
the dollar only
shows to be up because we compare it to
toilet paper
i mean we compare it to the yen which is
hilarious and we compare to the euro
which is just as bad
and because those went down more dxy
went up
a little bit not even a lot but we are
down versus the rem beat now which is
over the last couple weeks you know
whatever
the chinese are playing a different game
they
i believe intentionally
are
creating this nonsense you know supply
chain garbage to create a greater
alignment with them
they started with southeast asia and
africa now they've got russia and they
are creating this massive
axis
of alignment that all are going to move
to use the remnb
and
over time the petrodollar system will
weaken
and erode without the petro dollar
system
we're just a little country that does
eight percent of global trade